The first step in getting your game to
make money is to make your game fun.
Build a game that everyone wants
to play and pay money for.
Of course,
that's easier said than done, and
this is why learning about
engagement is important.
Game engagement is all about
how to design your game
to have that addictive quality
that keeps players wanting more.
It's really important for monetization
because the more your game is played and
your users drawn into your game world,
the more money your game will make.
Take Candy Crush as an example.
When I play it, I'll play whenever
I have a moment to myself,
like when I'm on the bus or just
trying to seem busy on my phone, and
I'll try to get to the next level.
It's really simple to play and there
are always more levels for me to get to.
Just look at this level map.
I have so far to go.
I feel like I have to keep playing, and
these levels are part of why
Candy Crush is such an addicting game.
I even got my mom hooked, and
now she's a lot better at it than me.
So levels, like in Candy Crush,
are great ways to keep players coming
back, wanting to go further in the game.
But they aren't the only way.
Let's look at what
makes a game engaging.
In this lesson, we'll talk about how
to get the right level of difficulty in
your game, adding competition in
your games, making your game easy to
access and play across multiple devices,
and also turning your players into fans.
These are the four components that
we've seen all engaging games include.